こんにちははじめしゃちょーでしたまごっち知ってるかな冒険へは確か小学校ぐらいの
時からといけないからもたまごっちってもなかったんですけどもう卵型のへと液晶の
画面がついているこういう小さいおもちゃなってその中でモンスターではないですねお
友達だね
モンスターではありませんよお友達さったまごっちという名前のね
お友達はね育てる猫
小さいゲームがあったんですよ子供の頃なんか育てるのが好きだったから雨ごっちゃに
こうちょいちょいちょいって行ってた覚えがあるんですけどもそのたまごっちがこの
現代において主芸進化してます
はいこちら最新などのたまごっちたまごっち4 u +でございます全8色あります
お寿司の玉子みたいなか見下してるわけなんですけれども
俺は誰の事じゃねーよそ設置みたいなん
おおこんな感じだそうもうなんか進化酒席ででやばいんですけど見た目がもうねすごい
ねシンプルなデザインになりますねボタン3つは変わってないです
メタリックなこの女フレームがすごいかっこいいですねたまごっちの魅力はですねその
成長吹きますちゃんたまごっちが卵からはず待って8月反抗期
フレンド
木さらに今回ことに個性的というのは新しい成長が見られるらしいです
名前と性別誕生日ね星座趣味長らの夢つける塗料の特技月な人好きな人だったんだ
おなかがすいたら食べ物をあげてコミュニケーションとディトイレをしてうわをに入り
目が汚れたら掃除してお出かけしてゲームして公園で遊んでがっ
今日お見合いもできるのねお見合いをして結構してしっかりたまごっちを育てるわけな
んですけども俺がたら事作用に座ってたのは小学校のときくらい今の俺は小学生では
ない
そうだろう青砥なあこのを吊らに行った始め今ならきっとそう
天才の俺ならさらに多くのたまごっちを
一気にリッキーに育てられると思った理由なんか今回はこの魂ごっつ1個だけを責め
てるわけじゃなんてこちらもうつばコツ育てるプロなんでこの天才初めにかかるとター
ボっち100匹全員しっかり育て上げて見合いできる結婚できる連嶺ま
磯田てますよ
掃除機できるかわかんガードいってみよできますよ
ただあの未知の領域なんでもうちょっと何かを切りが自分のよくわかんない
何なり一部的なこれを止めかもうこっちゃいいねを止めかこれは乙女かこいつは
いろんな色の束と茶を作ることまで行きまーすって言って個性的なたまごっちがなんと
かって言ったところでここからです
まず
ぶーぶーっ
レンジ
役だったん
はい+と1個ありました
[音楽]
ここからだこの後たまごっちの日付と時間の設定をします夕方の6時
誕生日僕は2月の中4日ですね名前を入れてねはい
今度行きですねはい媚びててうっとー
卵を受けましたこれで卵が孵化するの持つのかな
超亀ている
ポッ二大
ああ
ああこんにちはは
おめでとう的なんです
割れちゃったよね
こんにちはーはじめはいありがとうございます今お腹がすごい
空いている状態ですねめすか女の子でしたねせずご飯を食べさせなきゃ
[音楽]
炒めますはいというこんな感じでございますねおめでと
待て沿ってないような前に入れ上からね
詰まってる今名前入力してるからねー
ちょっと今名前入力してご飯後で返されてるからなってます
アレッポ風邪ひいてんじゃんと風邪ひいている1人目がもうちょっと病気っぽくなって
ますまずはで直さなきゃじゃまたなって今始まって
東京球待ってで待っててね待っててねまたはどうと思ってね
ほんでまたはちゃってっ
[音楽]
これやべえずはダメですこれええ
みんな生まれてきてくれてありがとうただこの子達初心
みんな病気になってじゃあみんな具合悪そうにしてるんですよいま8割くらい具合は
理想にしてますまあ
いたわるだいた割れば治る9 h と皆様旧とりあえず直していきたいと思っています
寝てる子は ok なが寝てる光景が出てきましたねー
ダメでちょっと間に合ってないですね厳しいぞこれは
何が起きて4スポツ成長した
誰なにこの白いのディオネチって名前らしいですねりよねっち
みんな神ができるとてもいいながんばれ
この中天童みたい天道君かなあ
寝ながら病気になっちゃう朝日と同じだくるよね
今反抗期ですね今皆反抗期に入りだします
みんな体調悪くも進化し白してるぞお腹は大丈夫アンダース入ってるねごはんされ
ましょね
あっヒム進化するけどね ok ちょっと待ってねチームが取れず病協のおそ
ok
けあ誰か進化した今のご飯お腹いっぱいね ok だよ君はどうする
お腹は同大めっちゃ進化 p ございま
[音楽]
ふうに騒がしくなってシーンといいましてつまりましたはい今夜なのでなんか未満で
出しましたねこれが明日の朝になると強いんだよな
ねずみ打で出るということで初日は何とか乗り切ったらじゃないでしょ
具合悪い状態で寝てる子達もいたんでその形はとりあえず明日の朝に何とか直せればと
思っております
おやすみなさい
はいおはようございます朝です際何人かも朝起きてきてマース早う
端張って言ってますね具合が悪いままでちゃったこのいるんでそいつらのケアをまずし
ていきたいと思っております
追っている探しから始めてみんなが起きればに負けてる奴らだけでもとりあえず
しっかり入ったちょっと覚えておこう
ni
だいぶみんな元気になってきました結構みんな元気になってきたんですけども急にその
パッドを受けられるとお父さんも参っちゃうからねえじゃあみんなでドライだ僕は猫の
今早起きしたお友達と遊んじゃうぞ
ポスコやばいぴょんっぴょんっを
ほら俺を点どっちと県どっちが一緒に写真撮ってるメンズ友達で102いるわけだから
覚えてじゃあそれを出るぞ
目立つ一緒の家に全員見合うことできないかもしれないね
[音楽]
オハヨーっ
誰
誰も来た2人来たえっやばい置き始めた
おやべあ起き始めた背景髪の毛始めたいったんですよね2画面な最悪でございますこれ
で日中はお世話してくれる感じなのかな
じゃあみんなおはようみんなにあの会社に行ったり学校に行ったり
デバッグ1日中寝たまごっちおこうねそれ
出ている暇はないと思うんですよ100人の魂たに来てもらいましょう
ただしいった読めない子がたまにいるんだけど楽しいった呼べない時がある
あー愛情度が0の時に預けられないということか
やばいやばい何かも愛情が0になってる人たちが入ってその形はもう魂体に預けること
ができないっぽいですでは
だまあ一国はそうじゃんじゃまずい相撲ちょうど女ないぞ
ず愛情は葉山預けられぬ
[音楽]
car
結果から申し上げますと
100匹涼みたはん
女でした0
あいこういう感じでほとんどのたまごっちは手紙を残して家出してしまいました
九重にだけはまだ僕のそばにいてくれてますあとの90校
いいいいいいいい
うーん物理的に無理だな
強で物理的に目です頑張ってそれぞれのアブ10匹ぐらいだと僕は勝ちましたんもうね
手が回らないみんなも僕のことが逆になって入れてしちゃったんですけども今回家で
知ってしまって中10個の誰もどっちは皆さんにプレゼントしようと思います岡田警笛
は他の子達になって
幸せにしてもらってほしい動画概要欄から応募フォームがあるのでそちらから是非
たまごプレゼントもうしてください90名様でございます7本当に100匹はマジで
忙しかったです
もう今までに一番難しかったと言っても過言じゃないよね大変だったんですけどもう卵
を注いすごい可愛くてちょっと愛着が湧いちゃってこうなんとかしろ何とかしようと
思って何度
ができませんでしたできればちゃんとみんなフレンド機までそれだったんですけど
ちょっと
数が多すぎたかなお似合いとか結婚とかまでさせたかったけどな
愛とイデホのたまごっち for you の育て方やお得な情報を知りたい人は誰も
こっちの youtube チャンネルがありますこちら
卵 tv こちらのぜえええ見てみてくださいこちらは動画の説明欄から url なり
ます百世
に本当に大変だったけど文字可愛かった朴正
一匹でいいかなん
ん
分の
[音楽]